bonjour à toutes et tous et merci d'être
là ce matin je vais donc avec eric
ciotti faire rapidement le tour
d'horizon et puis on répondra
naturellement à toutes vos questions
premier point
classique si je puis dire l'activité
l'agenda du président vendredi matin
dernier
vous le savez nicolas sarkozy était avec
gérard larcher et avec christian jacob à
l'elysée pour parler de la révision
constitutionnelle le président de la
république s'est engagé auprès de notre
délégation à ce que la réforme
constitutionnelle prévu reste sur les
deux points qui étaient envisagés
initialement c'est à dire l'état
d'urgence la constitutionnalisation de
l'état d'urgence et la déchéance de
nationalité pour les binationaux
le président sarkozy a donc dit à
l'issue
vous avez pu le voir que alain l'immense
majorité des républicains sénateurs et
députés votre et la réforme
constitutionnelle si elle restait sur
ces deux thèmes et sur ces deux thèmes
seulement alors inutile de vous dire
notre part étonnement parce que plus
rien ne nous étonne mais notre agacement
de voir que dès ce matin le président
des députés socialistes dit que ce ne
serait pas le texte qui serait proposé à
la révision constitutionnelle puisque ce
matin il dit pas question d'aborder le
thème par la binationalité et
possibilités pour l'assemblée nationale
notamment sa commission des lois de
réécrire le texte peut pas avoir d'un
côté un engagement du président la
république aux délégations politiques de
dire voilà ce qu'elle texte est ce que
vous prenez
ou pas la décision de le voter 1 et en
parallèle de nous dire que ben on verra
bien ce qui sort ce qui peut d'ailleurs
légitime et expliquer la position du
groupe républicain au sénat qui est de
dire ben nous on attend de savoir quels
textes sort de l'assemblée nationale
pour savoir quelle est la position mais
là le le côté chaotique à gauche devient
un peu exaspérant on peut pas avoir des
engagements du président de la
république du premier ministre
si en parallèle on n'est pas sûr du tout
que ces engagements puissent être tenus
et si on nous demande à nous l'unité sur
la lutte contre le terrorisme sur l'état
d'urgence sur la déchets
ensuite nous dire que c'est pas le texte
qui sera présenté devant
en réalité les députés les sénateurs
donc nous attendons de la part du
gouvernement de la part du parti
socialiste une clarification de ce que
cela veut dire
vous avez pu voir là dessus d'ailleurs
que nous sommes extrêmement clair nous
sur la déchéance sur l'état d'urgence et
sur cet état d'urgence je vais tout de
suite donné la parole à eric ciotti
puisque ce qui vient de se passer à
calais et quand même quelque part lui
non pas une et gassion mais plus qu'une
infraction par rapport à l'état
d'urgence
eric merci roger ce qui s'est passé ce
week end à cadets traduit en effet le
fait qu'il n'y a sur cette partie du
territoire national ni état d'urgence ni
surtout état de droit les événements
particulièrement graves qui se sont
produits à calais traduisent la perte
d'autorité de toute autorité du
gouvernement sur une partie du
territoire de la république
c'est particulièrement grave c'est
particulièrement scandaleux
les images que l'on a vu défiler en
boucle et cette vidéo qui démontre
combien l'état républicain aujourd'hui
est dans l'incapacité de faire respecter
les lois de la république où on voit un
ferry pris d'assaut comme autant de la
piraterie par des militants no border et
par des personnes qui ont dans trois
heures bloqué le port de calais ces
images de la statue du général de gaulle
à calais avec ce tag nique la france
sans réaction adaptée à la gravité de la
situation par ceux qui sont en charge du
maintien de l'ordre est extrêmement
grave extrêmement choquant et nous
voulons
le dénoncer avec beaucoup de force et
beaucoup de détermination
il faut que le gouvernement se
ressaisisse à calais il faut que
l'autorité républicaine réinvesti cette
partie du territoire qui aujourd'hui on
a le sentiment est livré à la loi des
passeurs à la loi des bandes et ona et
ce mot est terrifiant au 21ème siècle
sur une partie du territoire de la
république
une jungle 4000 au moins deux personnes
y résident ray si j'ose ce mode de
résidence
en tout cas composerait ce territoire de
non droit c'est là aussi absolument
choquant donc nous demandons aujourd'hui
des mesures immédiates sur 15 9 continue
de parler comme le gouvernement le fait
sur l'ensemble de ces sujets mais sans
aucun résultat
nous demandons le démantèlement immédiat
de la jungle de calais n'est plus
possible qu'il y ait des lieux dans des
conditions sanitaires aussi déplorable
des lieux où plus aucun service public
de puissent pénétrer notamment les
pompiers les médecins ou les policiers
qu'il y ait ce démantèlement immédiat
comment procéder à ce démantèlement est
bien tout simplement en prêtant les
personnes qui y figurent dans le cadre
des lois de la république
il y a dans ce camp à la voie des
demandeurs d'asile qui ont déposé une
demande auprès de la préfecture et qui
est instruite par l'ofpra et il y à ce
qui est la majorité des personnes
puisqu'on estime que sur les 4200
figureraient 1400 demandeurs d'asile
c'est à dire moins d'un tiers un tiers
deux tiers seraient des étrangers en
situation irrégulière
nous demandons que les demandeurs
d'asile soient placés dans des centres
d'accueil de demandeurs d'asile et cada
et que ceux qui sont en situation
irrégulière soient placés immédiatement
dans des centres de rétention afin qu'il
soit reconduit à la frontière dans les
meilleurs délais puisque il devrait
faire l'objet d'une obligation de
quitter le territoire dont démantèlement
immédiat du camp nous demandons par
rapport à ce qui s'est passé ce week-end
la dissolution des associations qui
encourage qui entretiennent qui organise
la bouillotte la violence et notamment
les no border nous demandons également
une expulsion du territoire national la
plus rapide possible de tous ceux qui
troublent l'ordre public
c'est un motif d'expulsion qui existe
aujourd'hui
le gouvernement ne recourent pas nous
dénonçons cette passivité sa passivité
il faut que les étrangers qui troublent
aujourd'hui et qui menace l'ordre public
soit expulsé s'empare des du territoire
national tout cela et ses dérives de
plus en plus violentes auxquelles nous
assistons et que nous constatons
traduisent le déficit d'autorité du
gouvernement traduisent la démission du
gouvernement
face à ces questions migratoires
traduisent les erreurs répétées du
gouvernement
au plan européen et ces erreurs sont
certes partagé en tout cas la france
anna était sans doute avec l'allemagne
l'acteur principal et ses erreurs vont
se reproduire demain au delà de ce
contexte d'actualité particulièrement
préoccupant puisque nous examinerons
demain soir à l'assemblée nationale le
projet de loi sur l'immigration
initialement baptisé et c'est tout un
symbole texte projet de loi pour le
droit des étrangers
opportunément rebaptisé par le sénat
mais il n'y a que le nom qui va rester
des travaux efficace pertinents et
opportuns qui avait conduit les
sénateurs pour donner
véritable cadre d'intervention à ce
texte qui ne soit pas celui voulu par le
gouvernement mais qui autorise au
contraire une meilleure maîtrise des
flux migratoires dans une période où ces
flux sont devenus totalement incontrôlée
avec un million cent mille migrants qui
sont arrivés l'année dernière en europe
certains évoquent le doublement de ce
nombre pour l'année 2005
la france a connu une augmentation de 22
% des demandeurs d'asile donc il y à une
dégradation de tous les paramètres de
cette situation et c'est à ce moment où
la situation devient contrôlée et
maîtrisée où les inquiétudes sont les
plus fortes que le gouvernement va
proposer un texte qui est un texte
caractérisée par un angélisme coupable
par rapport à l'immigration puisque le
sénat avait voté un plafond qui serait
défini chaque année par le parlement
pour définir quelles capacités d'accueil
notre pays était susceptible de quelle
il était super septembre de porter en
gros c'était des quotas migratoires
prendre ce nom ce beau le gouvernement
qu'à la commission des lois la semaine
dernière l'assemblée revenu avec
l'accord du gouvernement sur cette
disposition qui prévoyait que chaque
année le parlement vote des plafonds
migratoires nous redescendrons d
amendement dans ce sens de m'asseoir
mais sans grande capacité de succès le
sénat avait également supprimer l'aide
médicale d'état pour la transformer en
aide médicale d'urgence la commission
des lois et le gouvernement ont rejeté
et sont revenus sur cette disposition
et surtout il y a dans ce texte
des mesures qui vont complexifier les
procédures d'éloignement nous avons
besoin aujourd'hui d'aller beaucoup plus
loin sur l'éloignement
on a vu les chiffres de l'éloignement
que les chiffres de l'éloignement des
éloignements était en baisse en 2015 et
c'est encore à ce moment au plein coeur
de la crise migratoire que le
gouvernement choisit pour faire adopter
un texte particulièrement
laxiste sur les questions migratoires un
jour ajoute juste là dessus puisque j'ai
été l'un des principaux acteurs orateur
au sénat je suis assez choqué parce que
le ministre de l'intérieur dans le débat
au sénat qui n'est pas si ancien que ça
vous disais dans cette période d'unité
nationale évidemment le gouvernement
sera très attentif à toutes les
propositions de la droite parce que
quand il demande à la droite être unis
avec le gouvernement sur la lutte contre
le terrorisme sur la maîtrise des choses
évidemment il faut qui est par
définition une main tendue si je puis
dire des deux côtés or systématiquement
nous constatons que tout le travail qui
a été fait au sénat dans les commissions
pour trouver des solutions pas des
solutions extrêmes et pour trouver des
solutions
et bien tout ce travail a été balayée
avec l'accord du gouvernement par la
commission des lois de l'assemblée
ce qui veut dire que lorsque le texte
sortira de l'assemblée reviendra en
deuxième lecture au sénat
on peut se demander si même le sénat
acceptera d'en discuter
ça ne sert à rien de nous dire on est
prêt à parler on n'est pas à discuter
pour dès que le texte repart du sénat
naturellement tout soit enlevée et
reviennent sur les vieilles lunes
socialiste là je dois dire qu'on est
assez scandalisé quant à bernard
cazeneuve qui a dit hier que c'était la
septième fois ou qui y est elle est
cette fois calé et qu'il souhaitait
rétablir
je cite l'ordre public à calais comme le
dit très bien
eric c'est bien de le dire l'incantation
ça suffit quoi maintenant on veut des
actes de vrais actes et quand on voit le
texte qui revient devant soi qui va
revenir au sénat on se dit que bonds a
bien nous on a droit aux discours
on n'a jamais droit aux actes concrets
temps dans la même chose puisque j'étais
sûr
l'agenda du président sarkozy vous avez
pu voir que hier il est allé à la messe
de réparation à fontainebleau
pas du tout parce que d'un coup il ya un
mélange laïcité et problème religieux
mais parce que simplement quand on
regarde sur 2014
sur l'ensemble des actes touchant des
lieux de culte 470 atteinte au lieu de
culte chrétien 60 à peu près pour les
lieux de culte juifs 60 pour les lieux
de culte musulman c'est vrai qu'on parle
beaucoup plus que normal logique
classique des atteintes sur les lieux de
culte juif ou musulman mais il ya quand
même beaucoup beaucoup d'agressions
beaucoup de deux dégradations de lieux
de culte chrétiens donc c'était un
signal
juste pour dire que on n'oublie pas
enfin et avant de vous laisser la parole
deux petits éléments comme ça d'abord
vous avez pu voir que le conseil
constitutionnel avait en partie
invalidée le dispositif du tiers payant
généralisé qu'avait souhaité porter la
loi santé on l'avait dénoncé pendant les
débats parlementaires on avait dit que
naturellement le système était
inégalitaire
on n'a pas été écouté par le
gouvernement le conseil constitutionnel
a donc en grande partie invalidée ce
dispositif et enfin juste pour le fun
pour ceux qui ont regardé les
télévisions ces jours derniers bon
rien à dire la télévision sont libres
mais peut-être que madame najat vallaud
belkacem pour est comment dire
quelque peu durcir son positionnement
par rapport à ce qu'elle a entendu alors
considéré qu'elle était surprise par les
propos de barack à city pendant
l'émission du supplément et qu'elle est
resté très flou sur son retrait ou sa
condamnation mais je pense que la mise
de l'éducation gagnerait à faire un
communiqué condamnant clairement les
propos qui ont été tenus parce que les
propos qui consiste à dire que l'égalité
hommes femmes est une chose tout à fait
secondes pour ne pas dire inexistante et
qu'on ne veut pas condamner aussi
clairement que tout le monde
les actions de neige d'un peu compliqué
qu'un ministre de la république ne soit
pas clairement dans la condamnation pure
et simple de ce qui s'est dit ou sur ce
qu'on a pu voir sur d'autres chaînes ou
en ce moment on a un peu le sentiment
circulent des pétitions mais bon on a un
peu le sentiment que les médias pardon
de vous le dire devant vous mais c'est
un peu compliqué de dire c'est l'état
d'urgence c'est un peu compliqué de dire
tout le monde doit faire face au
terrorisme
et puis de voir sur des ondes des gens
qui ne sont pas aussi condamnant des
actes de terrorisme que nous pouvons
l'être tous quel que soit le bord
politique auquel nous appartenons
voilà eh bien il me reste à vous dire
c'est à vous et tous les deux à votre